Katrina travels at 10 miles per hour. Great work if you found this number. We
can start solving this equation by multiplying through by the LCD. The lowest
common denominator in this case is x minus 5 times x plus 5, the product of
these two denominators. When we multiply we'll get 15 times x plus 5 here plus
15 times x minus 5 here. Equal to 4 times x minus 5 times x plus 5. I
multiplied these two binomials together since we have a minus b times a plus b.
That's a squared minus b squared, our difference of squares pattern. Next we
distribute the 15 here and here and we distribute the positive 4 to get this
new equation. Combining like terms on the left side of the equation, we'll have
15x plus 15x which equals 30 x. The positive 75 and the negative 75 sum to 0.
Next we want to try and factor this quadratic equation. So we'll need to move
this 30x over to the right hand side in order to set the quadratic equal to 0.
I'll list the 4x square term first then the negative 30x term and then negative
100. All of these terms are even, so we can divide our entire equation by two.
Here we'll want to use factoring by grouping in order to factor this quadratic.
We find factors of 2 times negative 50, which is negative 100 that sum to
negative 15. Negative 20 and positive 5 multiply to give us negative 100 and
they sum to negative 15. So we'll use these two numbers to rewrite negative 15x
as negative 20x plus 5x. Then we just use factoring by grouping to get two
factors of 2x plus 5 and x minus 10. We set each of these factors equal to 0 so
x can equal 10, or x could equal negative 5 halves. We know x really represents
Katrina's speed. So, we can't use the negative value. It's invalid. This is how
we know Katrina travels at 10 miles per hour.